- [Instructor] Oliver
and Theo have lived on
they're parents' sailboat
for over three years.
So this version of they're,
T-H-E-Y apostrophe R-E,
this is a contraction for they are.
They are.
So let's see if it makes sense
if we were to replace this.
We should be able to
replace the contraction
with the thing that it's contracting.
So let's see.
Oliver and Theo have lived on they are
parents' sailboat for over three years.
So this clearly does not make sense.
The intent isn't to write
the contraction of they are,
the intent is to write
the possessive of they.
And the possessive of they is T-H-E-I-R,
not T-H-E-Y apostrophe R-E.
These get confused all the time.
I've been guilty of it when
I've been typing really fast.
My brain just kinda
says what it sounds like
instead of saying, hey, wait, wait,
I need to use one their
versus another they're.
So T-H-E-I-R, so their parents,
and then we this apostrophe after the S.
Now this would, you put
the apostrophe after the S
is if this is a plural possessive.
And this is.
We're not talking about
one parent's sailboat,
we're talking about
their parents' sailboats.
So multiple parents' sailboats.
So we would go with their parents'.
So this one right over here.
So we definitely want to change it,
we don't want to say they
are parents' sailboat.
This one right over here
still says they are, they're.
So rule that one out.
And this one right over here,
they got rid of the apostrophe.
There's no apostrophe right over here.
And you need apostrophe,
because we're talking about,
well, whose sailboat is it?
Well, it's the parents, it's the parents.
Their parents' sailboat.
So it needs to be a possessive, parents'.
So you need the apostrophe
right over there.
So rule that one out as well.